il ya un célèbre député de meaux
mais c'est pas jean françois copé
c'est le général de la fayette
ça explique quand même beaucoup de
choses hein jean françois copé s'en est
sûrement pas mal inspiré qui a dit aucun
obstacle ne me détourne ni me ralentit
dans le but unique de ma vie aucun
dans le but unique de ma vie alors moi
je suis venu vous dire ce soir
qu'aucun obstacle ne me détournera de
cette campagne
aucun obstacle ne me détournera sur le
chemin de la reconstruction de la france
à ce que nous avons un devoir celui de
reconstruire une nation unie autour de
valeurs partagées autour d'une identité
autour d'une fierté de notre histoire
est rien rien n'est plus fort qu un
peuple fier un peuple fier un peuple
français pierre c'est un peuple
invincible alors vous savez notre mentor
à tous les deux ça fait jacques chirac
et jacques chirac qui nous a appris
quelque chose il nous a appris quelque
chose il nous a appris que rien dans une
élection n'était joué avant la dernière
minute alors moi je vous le dit
n'écoutez aucun sondage n'écouter
personne
n'écoutez pas ceux qui vous disent que
cette élection s'est terminée que cette
élection s'est pliée aujourd'hui cette
élection c'est vous qui allez la faire
parce que vous avez l'art peuvent
quelque chose d'inestimable s'appelle un
bulletin de vote alors je vous demande
ya 25 jours d'aller convaincre d'aller
convaincre les indécis d'aller
convaincre autour de vous de leur dit
que nous avons un rêve pour la france
que nous voulons une france plus fort
que nous voulons une france plus juste
que nous voulons une france réconciliée
alors les amis es ce que vous avez envie
que le nom de la france résonne que l'on
la france tonnes le long de la france et
tonnes chers amis es ce que vous avez
envie de traverser les tempêtes avec moi
est ce que vous avez envie d'aller au
combat
est-ce que vous êtes prêts pour la
victoire
moi je le suis alors suivez-moi vive la
république et vive la france
[Applaudissements]